the characters from the hit series
Breaking Bad are back in the sequel film
El Camino a breaking bad movie Netflix
says more than 25 million households
watched the film in the first seven days
of its release the Breaking Bad series
ndred ended in 2013 can't believe it's
been that long
it followed chemistry teacher turned
drug kingpin Walter White and his
partner in crime Jesse Pinkman the
sequel movie uses flashbacks to reveal
what happened at the end of the series
while Pinkman was in captivity I hate to
be all like but we gotta talk ground
rules if you tried to you know escape
I'm gonna have to visit the little boy
it'll basically be out of my hands at
that point
Uncle Jack made you that promise and
he's gonna want to stick to it so good
behavior right right
I appreciate it Jesse actor Aaron Paul
freezes it reprises his role as Jesse
Pinkman he joins us with actor Jesse
Plemons who plays Todd one of the
ruthless killers we took Pinkman captive
good morning you just think it's a
little weird clip to show at this time
let me start with you Aaron cuz a lot of
people think that Breaking Bad had like
the perfect ending to it so when you get
a phone call from the creator of the
show Vince Gilligan saying we want to
keep going what did you think I mean you
know I I said yeah you know I I just
trust Vince with everything that is in
me so if he's involved I will follow him
and I agree I think I thought Breaking
Bad had the perfect game at a perfect
and why mess with that but Vince doesn't
want to tell you know if you want to
tell a story there's a reason for that
yeah your ending wasn't so perfect just
because you died in Breaking Bad but you
get to come back through flashback
scenes and one of the great scenes in
the movies you singing the song sharing
yeah
no-no-no yeah it's in there he knows the
words so when they came to you were you
excited about doing a singing scene
because I would think as an actor being
able to do a singing scene would be
great fun under any circumstance yeah I
suppose so but especially for Todd yeah
it shows such a such an interesting side
of him that you didn't really see in the
show and what was interesting to me
about the movie was the way Vince and I
had talked about it it's kind of tied on
one of his best happiest days aside from
because one of his best happiest days
involves a body in the car you must have
been excited because you called Erin to
play a tape of you singing I did yeah I
knew I knew read the script when he sent
me a voice note of that song oh my god
it's just so just one of those started
creeping him out yeah this is the the
tractor-trailer was pulling up with you
gave the honk signs
yeah that's an ad-lib yeah yeah it was
it was it was something that that just
came to me when I did you think you'd be
able to get into character so easily
could an old friend yeah did you have to
go look at all episodes or you know
because it's it's really was like
revisiting an old friends you shot your
scenes without rehearsal I read I mean
kind of just read the script as many
times as possible I just knew this story
and I knew my lines I kind of approached
it like a play in a way I just knew the
script and then I just kind of showed up
on the day and you hope for the best
for spontaneity that's nothing is so
amazing so you're in the character so
much so that you imagine what is not on
the script but the character would do
would be consistent like that as well
yeah and then I did that very Breaking
Bad during certain moments and I'm like
alright well let's just see what happens
and when the cameras rolled that's
there was a lot of secrecy surrounding
this production what lengths did you go
to to mask what you were up to a lot of
lying yeah like lying about what who who
you like you in the movie are you
[Laughter]
stockin yeah and then on sets depending
on the location sometimes I made us wear
these giant cloaks heading to set which
I thought caused a lot more attention
apparently Awards and Bryan Cranston
came back I thought that was interesting
cuz that did because the way the movie
goes forwards and backwards I kept
thinking now is this happening now is he
coming back but clearly it was just a
flashback but it was so nice to see the
two of you together again
yeah and that that that scene would take
place during my favorite episode which
is called four days out and it was just
uh it was so nice to reconnect again
yeah we've got a weekend coming up now
so they can plow through all the breaks
bad yes plow through the show and then
get into the movie that's what I offer
get go see Bruce's movie and see
Breaking Bad but this isn't Netflix
never releases figures about how
anything is doing but they did have a
new release when they're really happy
they'd yeah 25 million plus people have
already watched this you guys are both
relatively new dads too congratulations
thank you yeah and they love each other
baby summits have occurred yeah yeah and
neither one of them can see this movie
all right guys congratulations come on
nice really nice to see you Jesse
Plemons the movies call El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie a Breaking Bad movie
streaming right now on Netflix right
this second